Kevin O'Leary is one of the most
successful certainly one of the most
famous investors and businessmen around
because
he's a TV star in addition to a
businessman he's on Shark Tank and has
been for 15 years we talked to him for a
brand new episode of Tucker Carlson
today here's part of it and it's a great
segue into another
conversation that I think is going to
interest you a lot the government in
all of those programs to put money into
the economy yes helicopter money
are being debated now were they too
rough shot were they too fast were there
not enough rules
PPP came you remember PPP very well
administered by the Banks so you could
just call your bank and if you qualified
which most small businesses did and
small businesses are defined by five to
five hundred people that's one measure
of them and they represent 62 percent of
our economy they are the essence of the
American economy and so it was a good
reason to try and save them and
they announced another program and I
didn't even know about this
I learned about it through this mandate
we're doing in North Dakota when
treasury funded these North Dakota
Venture fund they also find it something
else called
the employment retention credit
it's based off your W-2 so if you had
employees in 2020 in 2021 you can get up
to 26
000 cash per employee not as a loan as a
one-time Grant but not like PPP because
PPP was administered by the Banks but
you have a bank account of your business
you need to apply to a very arduous
difficult process for this
the program itself is 170 pages long
so nobody applied because when they
originally brought it out they said pick
PPP or the employment retention credit
so-called ERC but you only get one so
everybody went PPP the pandemic gets
worse it's now 2021 it's a total
collapse every business is shutting down
they change the law to say both you can
apply for both
so if you're a business
the government spent billions of dollars
back in 2020 or 2021
it's sitting there it's already gone
already spent program's already done in
fact the program's going to end in 25
months
and they're waiting for you to pick up
the cash
your cash it's yours it's like you left
your car in a parking lot you got to go
pick it up now
and nobody's ever heard of this program
so I got approached to be a paid
spokesman spokesperson for this and said
why can't you get the word out to
America and I said first of all I don't
believe it
um I would know about this if anybody
would know about this program with all
the companies I have
I would know about this and they said
you don't know about it you've never
heard of it I even talked to Governors
I'm working with they'd never heard of
it nobody's heard of it you've never
heard of it no
son of a gun it's real it's it's there
and so the first thing I did is I called
all my CEOs and said have you ever heard
of this none of them had I said I want
everybody on board I want this
application in there because now we're
paying up to 30 percent usury loans
because rates have gone up so high for
small businesses
and I realized we needed some real
horsepower to process this stuff by the
hundreds of applications so I set up
this thing called the Wonder trust
anybody can go to it whatever trust.com
I'll take you right to an expert and you
can get your money I am on a mission to
get to every company in America to learn
about this program before it ends in 25
months
this is if you're a small business you
know how tough factoring is now you know
hardest to get money for for Equity this
is this isn't alone it's a grant for
your business you got it back in 2020
2021 Go Get It Go Get It just go to
wondertrust.com I'm your advocate
go get it imagine if you have 50
employees
that's half a million bucks you got 100
employees that's a million one cash
now you've never heard of that money's
already spent already gone government
already granted it so it has no effect
on the federal budget if you take the
money no you you can't it's done it's
over
and if you don't apply in the next 25
months you'll never get it interesting
interesting perspective Kevin O'Leary
that conversation with Fox Nation right
now